the official release of uncle Zhu will
be Friday nationwide with reg c-webb
Kyrie Shaq Nate Robinson Lisa Leslie the
world premiere of the film tonight in
New York City so one of the stars along
with reges Chris Webber who joins us now
see Webb entering the man cave looks
like he could still play you gotta fake
it got a figure like a tight shirt on or
something Wow good how much sleep for
you last night Chris well that
microphone close to ya you didn't have
to do the red eye no no I didn't but my
I had a great delayed flight for six
hours so I stayed in the airport met
some nice people had some nice beverages
in the airport for about six thousand
guys so you didn't get a private jet
like reg and California is the one that
got Oh Shaq had the PGA was his cafe
that guy okay you imagine sitting next
to Shaq on a plane I give you his DJ
stuff no first of all he's too loud a
second have you guys seen Andre the
Giant doctor
are you sir I know Shaq's making a lot
of money doing a lot of things but are
you surprised he never went into WWE
where you know he could be like Brock
Lesnar
but I mean full-time where you just read
said you were great he said as far as
acting went you're too tall to probably
be an actor full-time but he said you
were great you would be an outlier I
said you're the 610 Denzel Washington
act in a school play or anything no I
worked I worked hard to dish and I had a
lot of fun and I knew some friends that
allow actors and I you know I've seen
you and you know you're great Adam
Sandler that's just game recognizing
game right there okay who did you talk
to about acting I talked to to a couple
of to a couple past actors but but what
helped me the most dan was that I played
a preacher and a basketball player
it's nothing sure so really my father
and a bunch of preachers are gonna hate
that I that they know I used their
cadence in the way that they talked and
spoken so I really just went to church
and thought about growing up in church
but not all vanellope and I try to those
moments was your dad a preacher no he
was a deacon no let me just say this is
real cool in the is a segment where I
preach and then this is cool my father's
dream was to be in the movie like to be
in a movie that was his whole dream I've
had charity events and he's like trying
to slip money to be the one
and I just asked these guys and thanks
to Marty and the producers and so in the
scene where I'm preaching my father
sitting right next to Lisa Lessig like
jumping up and down and the baby that
I'm Duncan is actually my daughter so
there's a baptism scene yeah that your
daughter that's my daughter yeah that's
my family affair Amen reg said that
there's the possibility of a sequel wait
didn't you hear it
yeah you said is there a possibility
yeah well how much does make up three
hours of makeup Monday through Friday
spent yeah three hours of makeup know
what a diva is but I'm a diva I'm not
doing it no once you get through the
three hours and it's time to actually
work we had so much fun but sitting in
that chair yeah that was the Reggie's in
shape so during the movie shooting shot
you know Reggie rides bikes up mountains
and he's going to Olympics for Ronnie
the rest of us we were hurting man like
getting massages on the set back hurtin
knees hurt news like you wouldn't be
able to tell you
Kairi didn't get hurt on the set then
that here are you going
now now you say did Kairi get her bridge
my job is just a house he did not get
hurt on the set of knobs room insider
information but we did nobly get
training on the set right oh how is that
we were on the venue no this was
business fun this was awesome we're
getting ready to do a scene and we are
all on that we love hot van it's hot
it's crazy all have our phones on us
right
the directors getting ready to say you
know lights camera action
and everyone everybody's phone just off
as if the cameras case is and I look at
rich and I'm like and Kyrie sitting here
and we're like no way Kyrie didn't have
his phone on him no no no he was the
profession yes but he he ran out he
seemed happy yeah yeah he knew something
he knew something was gonna happen we
were surprised that it was Boston yeah
yeah yeah but what do you do say to him
I was like dog did you see this and and
he looked and Reggie kind of said the
same thing and I think his brother came
out for full disclosure and he was just
like hell yeah and ran out the the van
and left us in there like divas do does
it star of the movie just left was there
hanging cuz yeah I guess he had business
to take care so then he left for a
little while probably had to make a call
or two yeah yeah so he can sort things
out with his agent yeah and he came back
all smiles and we were like okay and
he's like it's official yeah now I did
hear that Kyrie Irving beat you in a
shooting contest Papa Schadt was it Papa
Schatzi when Papa Schadt I mean David at
Dave & Buster's
there's shooting though but here's the
thing Kairi said he challenged and beat
Reggie in a shooting contest oh he
didn't yeah said Reggie kept saying that
he was still trying to get loose so I'm
gonna go to Chris I'm gonna go to see
went here because wrench doesn't lose
too many shooting cons you know he
doesn't and he never admitted if he did
lose he would not did Kyrie Irving beep
he did he did I'm gonna say he okay but
to my defense oh here we go
it takes a good hour and a half he Allah
has no bike on set my legs
[Music]
first of all Kyrie is 25 Reggie got the
form and everything Reggie was serious
it is no no but then after after he lost
to you know Kyrie heared about 30 in the
road from Papa shop who just got one too
late that's all did you guys ever have
any friction when you played against
each other I didn't have friction with
him I had friction with Vlad a because
Vlade was the instigator he was always
talking and flopping me talking about
matter but flop in so it was Vlad II
that I had problems I never had problems
with c-webb especially those great
sacramental teams yeah I was I was a big
fan of Reggie but I didn't like him
because he was always beating our teams
you know like he was the catalyst you
know I knew he was the ones gonna be
talking she's not getting into guys and
so he was a guy like you always wanted
to play with but when you playing
against him you just hate him he's
talking drunk you saw what he did to the
Knicks you see him kicking out this is
the human kicks they're not named
because when he shoots the three all
that bad leg stuff that he complains
about we do games yeah he might have
helped it's all that we were just
talking about Dirk Nowitzki should that
be legal that he lifts that knee up and
I mean so he creates separation he's
seven feet I mean it's he's unstoppable
with Durant have it now yeah yeah but he
can't do the knee if I'm up on reg like
this you can't just need me so you
already have to have that space so dark
one the greatest scorers ever he does
that after he has the space so it's not
as unfair creating the space he's just
keeping the space yeah exactly yeah he's
not giving you the knee and pushing off
reg use it as a weapon oh yeah love
tripping and leg whipping people leg
with before god it was like a joy to me
but then you would draw the foul yeah
look at you dummy go there how many
times did you bounce the ball seven
eight seven six
are you bounce the ball I'm gonna give
real lawyer the free toy it will be a
rise it's off Michael Jackson but Vlad a
probably created a lot of situations
that his teammates had to clean up for
well let's just think about it the flop
you came in to the European a thousand
percent why you see soccer yeah you see
this stuff in soccer is there worse
flopping in the world yeah Vlada ichirin
it's all these guys brought over because
during practice are actually playing
soccer so they brought that culture over
and Reggie did it where you know maybe
you bump him once or twice in the third
when is it fantastic these guys have
just come over we gotta sell it right
you gotta sell it and I would always say
the body man we gotta chill with the
floppy bloody would have played for Duke
right we're gonna take a break
see Webb and Reggie will stay with us
top of next hour Chris Webber going back
to Michigan
[Music]
yeah it's about time for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]